in the whole of Russian history there
have been the mere handful of men's
earned the nickname the great but there
has only ever been one woman Catherine
the Great was an empress who defined
both her circumstances and the opinions
of those around her to shape an entire
era bought into a minor German family in
the first half of the 18th century
she found herself thrust into the
spotlight when she married Peter the
third of Russia at the age of only 16
but rather than being a pushover
Catherine used her position to grab at
the imperial crown for herself Empress
of Russia from 1762 to 1796 catherine's
reign spanned global conflicts and
revolutions uprisings and royal
assassinations but she never lost sight
of her goal to forge a modern russia
from the ideals of the Enlightenment a
philosopher's empress to some an immoral
sex-obsessed harlot to others this is
the life of one of Russia's greatest
rulers say Catherine the Great's path to
the throne was an unlikely one it's a
little bit like saying Siberia gets a
touch chilly in the winter and the
moment she was born Sophie Frederic
Auguste on may the second 1729 the
likelihood of Catherine becoming ruler
of Russia was up there with me one day
becoming Emperor of Japan and by the way
Toki if the new guy doesn't work out you
know who to call
young Sophie who were just gonna start
calling Catherine right now to avoid any
confusion didn't have a drop of Russian
blood in her rather her father was a
minor German prince while her mother
Johanna was a slightly less minor
heiress to kraut he with ideas above her
station and those ideas emphatically did
not involve having a daughter from the
moment johanna discovered she'd pumped
out not a useful male heir but rather a
useless girl she treated Catherine less
like a human and more like a receptacle
for all of her disappointments johanna
called her daughter useless ugly and
told her that she was worthless it
probably didn't help the jarana herself
was amiss 17 when she became a mother
herself and that her arranged marriage
to Catherine's much older dad hadn't
exactly been a fairy tale it probably
also didn't help the Catherine went out
of her way to confirm Johanna
phears she was clumsy accident-prone
there's a story that she once managed to
dislocate her spine just by sneezing yes
even amid all these excursions into
klutz territory it was clear that there
was something more to Catherine than
journey gave her credit for when she was
just four she met the future King
Frederick the Great told two kisses ham
as a mark of respect she instead
demanded the Royal bow down to her so
that she could reach Frederick was so
tickled by this that he never forgot the
confident young girl yes it would be
another encounter that really defined
Catherine's childhood a grandson of
Peter the great Peter
Ulrich was a mere eleven years old when
he met the ten year old Catherine and it
was about as far from his famous
grandfather as could be imagined what
Peter the Great had been a dashing
warrior reformer his grandson was sickly
and neurotic he was also deeply damaged
left in the care of a sadistic tutor
Peter Ulrich had spent his life being
beaten tortured and humiliated by the
adult he was meant to care for him he
was made to stand at the dining table
the picture of a donkey hung around his
neck it was made to endure savage
whippings for the tiniest infraction in
our video today Peter Ulrich is going to
sort of take the role of the villain as
he does so do you remember the abuse
that he suffered as a child is at least
partly to blame despite their
differences Catherine and Peter his it
off during their first meeting becoming
not exactly friends but maybe friendly
acquaintances still there is no way
Catherine could have known what fate had
in store for them no way she could have
known that this sickly troubled loud was
the future Emperor that she was destined
to overthrow
[Music]
on the frozen night of December the
fifth 1741 a group of guards marched
into the bedchamber of Russia's infant
Emperor Ivan the 6th and arrested him
and his mother anna leopoldovna by the
morning of December the 6th both mother
and Charles had been locked away and
Moscow had a new ruler the daughter of
Peter the Great Empress Elizabeth was
the Imelda Marcos of the 18th century a
woman obsessed with clothes spectacle
and living the good life on the state
budget
she's surrounded herself with pomp and
fawning courtiers and forbade anyone but
herself from wearing pink but for our
story today the defining feature of
Elizabeth was that she was childless not
long after her coup against Ivan
Elizabeth decided to bang her self in
air by inviting Peter larec to Moscow to
be a son two years later
in 1743 a letter Landsman the hands of
Catherine's mother Joanna from Empress
Elizabeth this invited Joanna to come
and see Moscow along with her darling
daughter shortly after another letter
arrived this one from Frederick the
Great filled with subtle hints that the
Prussian King could help Joanna marry
her daughter off suddenly it looked like
catherine was going to Russia for Joanna
this was the fairy tale she'd been
waiting for a whole married life she
immediately set about spending the money
Frederick at forged her on fancy dresses
and heaps of jewelry these weren't for
Catherine though rather they were for
herself Jenna wanted to look absolutely
day that she'd dumped her useless
daughter on some unsuspecting Russian
Prince by winter 17:43 Joanna and
Catherine were on the road to some
Petersburg if you're wondering how
Catherine felt about being whisked away
to marry some dude she barely knew well
the answer is that it didn't really
matter this was Europe in the 18th
century arranged marriages were the norm
in the upper classes further aged only
14 Catherine had grown into a very
desirable Bachelorette she was witty
confidence and disarming although she
wasn't a legendary beauty she was
already fighting off marriage proposals
not least from Joanna's own brother
which must have been a bit awkward
finally after a very long very cold
journey Catherine and Joanna arrived in
Moscow the Imperial welcome they
received was so big so lavish that it
left no one in doubt about Catherine's
future role in the Empire now all she
had to do was actually meet Peter again
for all these years if Catherine had
grown up to be a charmer Peter Ulrich
had grown up to be the exact opposite a
miserable black hole that sucked all the
joy out of any room the boy hated Russia
he hated Elizabeth he hated Moscow and
he hated the fact that he wasn't in his
beloved Prussia at first the arrival of
the German catherine was a relief
finally someone who could understand his
misery
but while Peters idea of good time was
writing fan letters to Frederick the
Great and discussing how superior
bratwurst was debauched Catherine's was
rather different from the moment she
arrived in Russia the teenage girl had
fallen in love the Russia of the 1740s
was a distant mysterious place almost
entirely a rural with only a handful of
cities the religion was not Lutheranism
that Catherine had grown up with but the
exotic Orthodox rites of Eastern
Christianity for this girl from Germany
was an alien lands a place of endless
and fascinating contrasts and much to
Peter's annoyance catherine was
determined to fit in she began studying
the Russian language and she began her
conversion to the Orthodox Church by the
time she debuted at court on her 15th
birthday the upper classes they were
ready to love her it also helped that
Catherine could be just as charming in
Moscow as she was at home she always had
a killer quip ready or a
well-thought-out complement disarms
strangers she even got a reputation for
treating her servants as kindly as her
upper crust friends something of a big
deal at the time
before long Elizabeth had bestowed the
title of Grand Duchess upon her along
with the name Catherine or yekaterina in
Russian but while the Empress seemed to
have made a good choice in Catherine it
made a much worse choice in her own air
as Catherine grew more popular at court
Peter grew crueler towards her he told
her he was going to beat her once they
were married as that was the only way to
control a woman he also started getting
drunk and verbally abusing her but as
bad as Peter was already he was about to
get a whole lot worse not long before
their wedding Peter came down with a
case of smallpox a disfiguring disease
that would really advise against
googling it took him six weeks to
recover but he finally did his face was
so scarred that Catherine couldn't bring
herself to look at him bitter angry and
miserable Peter retreated from the world
locking himself in his room
and refusing to do anything but dress
his servants in Prussian Army uniforms
and play soldiers he only really emerged
for the lavish wedding on August the
21st 1745
but even then his bitterness got better
of him early in the evening Catherine
was sent by Elizabeth to the marital bed
to await beat her and get on with the
job of producing heirs instead Catherine
lay there for hours in the dark waiting
for a new husband
when Peter finally turned up he was so
drunk that he simply collapsed not a
word not a kiss not even a joke just one
unhappy teenager passed out on the floor
and another happy teen likely wondering
if this marriage had ruined her life
well if Catherine ever did wondered that
she was wrong as toxic as a marriage was
it would wind up making her into a
figure that's remembered by history all
she had to do was survive the next few
years
by late 1745 Elizabeth's enthusiasm for
Catherine had distinctly cooled there
still hasn't been any royal heirs so
Elizabeth wrote Catherine a stern note
reminding her that she better get
knocked up fast but there was very
little Catherine could do about it by
now Peter was actively avoiding sex
preferring to play twice soldiers and
live in a fantasy world
one evening Catherine came into their
rooms a find him putting a ratted Court
on trial when she asked him what he was
doing he declared the rat guilty and
sliced off its head in the wake of this
incident it's perhaps not surprising
that Catherine started having an affair
today Catherine's Affairs a legendary
but will come to all of that later for
now though she started sleeping with a
guy called Sergei saltykov possibly in
an attempt to get pregnant and possibly
with Peters knowledge yet a try as she
might Catherine just couldn't become the
baby producing machine that Elizabeth
wanted her to be and she did get
pregnant multiple times in but she
always miscarried before anyone knew
what was happening nine years had passed
and Catherine was still not a mother
that finally changed on October the 1st
1750 for that day baby Paul was born at
the end of a labor best described as
arduous the moment the baby was out
Elizabeth came in and snatched it away
to raise it herself Catherine for her
part was left lying alone in her own
blood for hours just too weak to move
with her air producing duties now ever
Catherine entered a new and depressing
stage in her life at the Russian Court
now that the baby was here everyone just
started ignoring her
they held a party to celebrate Paul's
birth while catherine was still
convalescing all she got was a drunk
Peter sticking his head in the door and
muttering something like well done
before going back to the party have
Catherine been another woman it's
possible her story would have ended here
finally beaten down by her awful new
family but this is Catherine we're
talking about a woman who has the Great
in her very name rather than give up she
spends her convalescence reading
Voltaire and plotting her return to
court on Peters birthday she finally
managed it kitted out in the finest
regalia Catherine crashed the party
inviting herself in unannounced and
restyling herself mother of the air with
breathtaking confidence she casually
snubbed those who had ignored her after
the labor she drops delicious poisonous
witticisms about anyone who tried to
stand up to her
from that point on Catherine would never
let
self get isolated again she cozying up
to the British ambassador accepting
bribes in return for information bribes
she used to buy herself a network of
informants as the 1750s swept by
Catherine began buttering up people in
positions of power leaders of army units
Arastoo Kratz anyone who might one day
be useful by the end of the decade
should even taken two important lovers
Stanislaw Poniatowski the future king of
Poland and Grigory Orlov the man who'd
make her Empress mus as powerful as she
now was catherine was still vulnerable
when she gave birth to her second child
Anna Peter came and watched the whole
thing
drunk out of her skull declaring that he
could do anything to her it must have
been a chilling thing to hear
and it also steal Catherine's resolve if
she ever wanted peace she was going to
have to get rid of her husband once and
for all
in 1756 a war broke out that engulfed
the whole world known as the Seven Years
War it involved most of the European
powers including pitting Russia against
Prussia as bad as the Seven Years War
was it was nothing but basil that was
brewing in the Russian Court by 1762
Peter had begun a public affair with
Elizaveta Vorontsova a coarse woman of
course of manners but all of that he was
parading around wearing Prussian
uniforms and telling everyone they
shouldn't be fighting Frederick the
Great
he was even promising Catherine that as
soon as he became Emperor he would have
her shaved bald and thrown in a convent
and this was a threat that was about to
become very real On January the 5th 1762
Empress Elisabeth breathed her last in
the wake of her death Peter was elevated
to the throne as Peter the third and one
of his first acts was to spend
Elizabeth's funeral procession openly
celebrating her death his second act was
to make his popular unwanted wife suffer
in the months that followed Peter the
third began inflicting humiliation after
humiliation on Catherine he dragged her
out in public and tried to make her
confess that their son Paul was
illegitimate but it wasn't just
Catherine Peter was getting his
vengeance on for a long time had hated
Russia and now he was in charge he was
going to dismantle the whole damn
country church property was strips and
givens at Lutheran ministries army units
were forced to drink toasts to Frederick
the Great everything became Pro Prussian
anti-russian and very auntie Catherine
for Catherine those months they must
have been an absolute nightmare but
luckily she was about to wake up their
summer July V aid Catherine's lover
Gregory olive abruptly came to her and
basically said how about we overthrow
this like right now and they did
the coup was organized by all of with
the help of his brothers and a guy
called Grigory Potemkin who were going
to come back to real soon it was simple
and bloodless dressed in a male uniform
Catherine rode out to meet army units
slaughter her as they joined more
declared their loyalty until it was
clear no one in Moscow stood against her
finally on July the 9th 1762 Catherine
was declared Empress Catherine the
second and that was that well almost
just outside Moscow Peter was drilling
some of his troops when word came in of
the coup but it wasn't as news that was
traveling in Peters direction Catherine
was riding out at the head of the army
said Oh Peter did the only thing he
could yeah
gated and threw himself at his wife's
mercy apparently he hoped to be send
into exile in Prussia but Katherine was
like no and had him placed under house
arrest
a days later Peter was dead the
historical record isn't clear and what
kills poor damaged Peter Ulrich
officially it was a nasty bout of
hemorrhoids but officially it's thought
he was strangled on the orders of all
off whatever the truth the result was
the same on September the 22nd 1762
Katherine was crowned impressive Russia
and a lavish ceremony at the Kremlin the
anonymous girl from Germany had finally
done it should survive the intrigues of
the Russian Court survived her marriage
to a madman and smashed through the
glass ceiling as effectively as a
Tomahawk missile but now came the hard
part
[Music]
in 1767 Catherine center legislative
committee a simple instruction known as
the instruction of Catherine the Great
had set out her vision for the future
under her watch Russia would conform to
the ideals of the Enlightenment things
like innocent until proven guilty that
become law the common goods it would be
emphasized the country's eight million
serfs would be considered people to are
is today this case ounds a little bit
like yeah about time but in eighty
century Russia this was a bombshell even
other European powers they were aghast
France actually banned copies of the
instructions who avoid a revolution and
all we can say to that is well good luck
historical France but while Catherine's
ideas were revolutionary her
implementation of them it was not rather
than acts like good little Enlightenment
thinkers her committee it fell to
squabbling then a war broke out and the
whole idea was completely forgotten the
russo-turkish war decimated catherine's
domestic of gender between 1768 and 1774
but at least it shored up her power
helped by the capture of Crimea still by
the time the dust had settled catherine
was twelve years into her rule and had
accomplished only a fraction of what she
wanted to do so she dropped any pretense
of governing by committee from now on
she was going to force her reforms
through by personal decree and what
reforms they were catherine opened the
first schools for orphans the first
hospitals for the destitute she
encouraged girls into education at a
time when most households valued women
somewhere below horses and about equal
with good footwear city governments they
were reformed to better serve the people
police were transformed from an
instrument for repression into one that
at least nominally helped ordinary folk
then there were the great cities
Catherine builds like the port of Odessa
where skilled immigrants were invited to
transform the economy she even undertook
the first detailed mapping of Russia
this is this great story where Catherine
was in a meeting when they're discussing
a far-flung town when Catherine asked
where it was all of our advisors just
shrugged so she sent someone out to buy
a map when they came back she discovered
that not even the map makers that
bothered to map most of Russia and well
that changed pretty sharpish but while
Catherine's reforms brought Russia into
line with its European neighbors they
weren't all successful rather how her
instruction called for the country's
eight million serfs to be considered
people
well those serfs were
basically slaves tied to the lands and
they were owned by local landlords when
Katherine realized her core support came
from those same landlords she did an
about-face and actually in Greece
serfdom and this touches on the other
issue of who benefited from Katherine's
reforms we mentioned earlier that 18th
century Russia was about 95 percent
rural yet the vast majority of
Catherine's reforms were in urban areas
as transformative as her domestic agenda
was millions of Russians didn't even
realize it was happening still her
reforms got a noticed abroad where
people like Voltaire championed her as a
great philosopher Empress but
Katherine's reputation it would soon
become international news again for a
very different reason it's time to talk
about sex
[Music]
so far in this video we've met three of
Katherine's lovers the guy who possibly
fathered pulled the guy who became king
of Poland's and all of the guy who
probably strangled Peter the third now
it's time to meet the most famous of
them all Grigory Potemkin had been a
background character in Katherine's life
for decades
it helped Olaf organize the coup that
overthrew Peter the third in the Raso
Turkish war had been the one who secured
Crimea and now he was back in the
imperial court determines due charm his
way into power to say Kathryn and
Potemkin were suited to one another is
to miss just how perfectly they matched
up Potemkin was ambitious and fearless
he was not exactly handsome but he was
attractive in a this guy doesn't give
two flying flips sawed away his ambition
also complimented Catherine's while
catherine was happy to lose herself in
details Potemkin was a big-picture
thinker able to spur her dreams to
greater heights
Catherine summoned him to court in 1774
before the year was out they were lovers
there's even some evidence to suggest
they married in a secret ceremony inside
a tiny backwater church with only two
witnesses it's certainly true she named
him Prince Potemkin and elevated him to
a stages near equal to co-ruler
but while their burning ambition is what
brought Catherine and Potemkin together
it was also what killed their love by
1780 both were fully aware that their
love of power was corrupting their
romantic relationship so they made a
deal from now on Potemkin would remain
as Catherine's political adviser but in
the bedroom he would be replaced not
with another ambitious powerful men but
with a string of anonymous studs and so
we come to the one thing about Catherine
the Great that everyone remembers her
sexual escapades the fact that this is
monstrously unfair goes without saying
Catherines contemporary Louis the 15th
had so many mistresses he could give
Prince a run for his money selling the
third at an actual harem but of course
it's the highly sexed woman who goes
down in history as using a horse to
satisfy herself story that's as fake now
as it was then stay classy
eighteenth-century propagandists still
there's no denying the Catherines
reputation abroad really did take a
beating in the back end of her reign and
not just because of her ill-founded sex
rumours in
in 89 that revolution France had been
trying to avoid well it finally broke
out based on a lot of those same
Enlightenment ideals that Katherine
professed to love but now those ideals
were questioning the Divine Right of
monarchs Katherine was suddenly all like
yeah I mean what enlightenment Voltaire
never heard of him when Poland's being
agitating for a French style liberal
Constitution in 1792 she forced the
second partition on the kingdom dividing
most of it up between herself Austria
and Prussia when Talia's Custer's goal
led a rebellion against the partition
two years later Katherine cracked down
as hard as any tyrant in Warsaw some
20,000 poles were executed in a single
day more people than died during the
entire reign of terror by the time
Katherine instigated the third partition
of Poland in 1795 wiping the nation off
the map her enlightenment credentials
had been reduced to a hollow punchline
but by then it belli mattered Grigory
Potemkin had died in 1791 leaving
Katherine isolated and lonely in his
place the Empress had begun to devote
all of her attention to her grandson
Alexander
even hinting that she would pass her son
Paul over for succession naturally this
created a deep rift in the imperial
family and left Paul eager to get one
over on his mother on November the 5th
1796 Katherine was found on the floor of
her bedroom almost carried off by a
stroke the very next day she died and
her grandson Alexander was still too
young to take over in his place Paul the
first ascended to the throne and he
quickly set about trashing his mother's
legacy the first thing he did was have
all of her papers burned just in case
that should written him out of her will
then he had poor Peter already dug back
up and given the state funeral that
Katherine had denied him finally he
ordered his mother buried alongside his
father after spending the early part of
their lives entwined in a toxic marriage
Katherine would now spend eternity
alongside her hated husband at the
moments of her death Catherine must have
wondered just how history would remember
her sure she'd expanded Russian
territory adding around five hundred and
twenty thousand square kilometres sure
she'd brought in liberal reforms and
modernized urban Russia but at the same
time failed in her goal of
abolishing serfdom just as she'd failed
to institute reforms that improved life
for 95% of the population who lived
outside of the cities so
then do we all remember her as Catherine
the Great well from a modern perspective
it's easy to see why just listen to our
life story a provincial girl who
overcame parental neglect forced
marriage and an abusive husband to
become one of the most powerful women in
Europe but even in the 18th century it
was clear that catherine was someone
special with her liberal reforms she
opened the door for a Russia that
existed to help its citizens and not
brutalize them while that dog would be
slammed shut again by successive regimes
knowledge of what lay behind it it never
really went away all those utopian
revolutionaries all those moments of
Thor in the 20th century those
shuttering moves towards openness in the
1980s all were distant descendants of
Catherine's attempts to mould her
country in a kinder image she may not
have always succeeded in her goals but
Catherine deserves to be remembered by
her title she really was the greatest
Empress in Russian history so I really
hope you found that video interesting if
you did please do hit that thumbs up
button below and don't forget to
subscribe we got brand new videos four
times a week hit that notification bell
when you subscribe so you find out about
those also why not check out another
channel I do called Geographics this
channel biographic sits about people
Geographics is about places and
geography things like that you could
probably tell from the name of the
channel please do go check it out
there's a link below and thank you for
watching
[Music]